sua boa tarde muito legal aqui com vocês
e em um ponto diferente a minha
apresentação razoável diferente mas
vamos lá há a seguinte quando apareceu a
idéia que eu achei muito boa a
obviamente do poder da reflexão
a primeira coisa que me ocorreu a 100 do
psicanalista além de professora aqui da
casa de vários outros lugares é trazer
esse tema por uma reflexão sobre si
consciência de si e quando o tema veio
veio realmente na cabeça como uma
associação uma tatuagem de um livro que
eu tinha lido realmente há 30 anos um
livro pouco conhecido - conhecido josé
saramago chamado manual de pintura e
caligrafia que é um livro muito lindo
que tem essa frase minha que eu acho
provocativo e boa
o verdadeiro lugar de nascimento é
aquele em que pela primeira vez se lança
um olhar inteligente sobre si mesmo
gosto muito não sei se eu entendi a
frase mas eu gosto muito dela e eu gosto
dela por um motivo muito bom ela coloca
a própria noção que eu tenho de estar
vivo e de ter nascido relacionado à
reflexão né eu na sua hora que eu lanço
sobre mim mesmo um olhar que eu reflito
sobre mim que eu me encontro no mundo e
que me sinto nele né
a reflexão na consciência de si
significa então que inicialmente pra mim
né desde a minha perspectiva a idéia de
que a gente é dividido em dois né eu sou
eu que a ge está aqui falando né e que
está agindo que está soando e que está a
isso no mundo da ação e um outro eu num
outro é o que se observa é que me faz
viajar enquanto um fala o que faz é
deixar um pouquinho inseguro do que eu
tô falando eu sou um que age eu sou um
que se auto observa né esse o fim só
deus e 2 já me coloca sempre para sempre
inacabado porque eu observo ameaçam
quando observa ameaçam eu me transformo
é essa questão da reflexão cambial
transformo me transformando eu tenho que
olhar pra mim de novo e quando me olha
de novo como transforme de novo e assim
ao infinito não refletir já coloca a
gente em acabamento que não tem jeito
não tem mais jeito né é um processo que
vai certamente prosseguir
indefinidamente refletir significa
literalmente ela própria de professor
que é o meu papo dobrar-se sobre
debruçar se refletir se desdobrar né
então tem um elemento da reflexão
que é um sair do fluxo importantíssimo
pra gente que é o fluxo
o fluxo é o nosso dia-a-dia entupido de
demandas né demandas da mídia social
demanda de trabalho demanda do afeto dos
amigos da família a demanda para todo
lado e vocês sabem se a gente tenta
atender a todas as demandas assim se
esvai tentando está sempre vendo alguém
não tem como a gente vencer esse negócio
né e essa demanda costuma ser tamanha
exigência tamanhos que elas ganham quase
pra gente e nos canais uma carga de
trauma
eu não me sinto que estou agindo que eu
estou vivendo eu sinto que eu só
reagindo
eu não sou exatamente agindo qual é a
diferença quando a gente faz a nossa
agenda mas a agenda hoje a qualquer dia
eu escolhi pra fazer o senhor falasse
comigo a devo mudar de rumo vamos lá
estava
fiquei preocupado efe
a idéia vai ser total na medida em que
eu estava assim né concorda que a
diferença como é que eu vou priorizar a
minha ação eu vou fazer agora aquilo que
faz mais sentido e é mais importante ou
fazer o que está mais atrasado e eu não
posso mais adiar é exatamente essa
diferença quando eu acho eu estou
priorizando aquilo que é significativo
aquilo que é real e é importante contou
a babá rotador de demandas eu apenas
reagiu apenas semana tiro coisa na
frente eu não faço trabalho eu tiro o
trabalho da frente a uma vez aprendi e
aprendo muito obviamente com alunos e 10
pm há quase 30 anos a tem muito a
aprender sempre né
uma vez perguntaram para um aluno numa
conversa akesson é pra você daqui cinco
anos dez anos né ele olhou pra mim e
falou como assim cinco dez anos sem
chances de pensar nisso eu quero saber
como é que eu chego vivo na sexta feira
é tudo que eu consigo pensar né essa
frase pegou muito pesado pra mim é
porque rigorosamente é isso né
há absolutamente abarrotados pela
demanda eu não consigo como falar agora
o roberto eu não consigo sonhar
eu não consigo ter perspectiva eu fico
colado no imediato a reflexão então me
tira do imediato roupa é voltar a me
tira do imediato e me faz colocar numa
outra perspectiva a sair de imediato
hoje especificamente o nosso hoje onde
nós estamos
quando é essencial porque está vivendo
obviamente não clima absolutamente
pavoroso e também de violência né
quando a gente está com medo né quando
está assustado a gente não pensa a gente
só reage a gente não vota a favor de
alguém e só volta contra o outro né
a gente não consegue pensar a gente
consegue se posicionar e eu sou certo se
eu ganhar
estaremos bem salvamos o mundo se o
outro ganhar o mundo vai acabar em
regime de urgência a gente não pensa em
regime de nos sentirmos violentados a
gente não pensa é urgente são só duas
semanas
a gente tem que sair dessa e pensar né a
pensar é então agora para o dia que o
slide que entrou errado na é a condição
justamente de abstração é o que toda a
filosofia faz todo o pensamento humano
faz a 45 mil anos neto talvez três mil
anos falar né
é claro que os canários e faz também é
uma condição de distanciamento do
imediato o que me faz ver como as coisas
funcionam em perspectiva sair da
ingenuidade da experiência para ganhar
condição de distanciamento
então peguei a pra quem me conhece
obviamente do meu ator favorito não é
uma situação para esta passagem é uma
situação que para quem conhece
psicanálise clássica do freud aqui disse
quando tiramos um cristal no chão ele se
quebra mas não arbitrariamente ele se
decompõe segundo as direções suas rendas
em pedaços cujas limitações apesar de
invisível já estavam determinadas antes
pela estrutura do cristal
você pega o cristal ele é um herói e
translúcido ele é simples quando ele
quebra revela-se uma estrutura que
estava lá o tempo todo na reflexão é
condição de crítica à condição de
análise é condição de distanciamento na
região fica mergulhado justamente na
experiência cotidiana
nesse sentido refletir obviamente ele é
imprescindível mas a reflexão também em
correm um risco muito grande
qual é o risco se agir sem pensar é um
horror
é estúpido simplesmente pensar sem agir
também o pensamento também pode me
deixar um plano de reflexão pura para o
qual eu jamais volto pra experiência eu
fico olhando de longe
superiormente para o mundo sem agir
nunca mais né
isso também é um risco do pensamento é
um risco da reflexão é preciso de alguma
forma então também tomar cuidado que uma
vez que ele saiba que eu preciso
refletir sair do fluxo e
preciso voltar o fluxo eu preciso voltar
para a vida e transformar essa vida né
vários autores falam sobre isso mas eu
peguei para falar sobre esse risco da
reflexão que fiquem se um craque em
reflexão na a um monólogo mais
importante é que a gente conhece o
teatro da peça hamlet de shakespeare
todo mundo conhece o começo obviamente o
ser ou não ser
é uma belíssima reflexão sobre se vale a
pena ou não estar vivo no setembro
amarelo a ea conclusão dele não é que
você pode imaginar né
em todo caso é depois de muito pensar
sem poder decidir
ele que é o grande pensador o grande
homem do monólogo fala do risco do
pensar demais
o risco é esse lá depois de ser um ser e
assim a reflexão faz todos nós covardes
e assim o matiz natural da decisão se
transformando doentio parte do
pensamento enfrentadas de vigor e
coragem refletidas demais saem de seu
caminho perdem o nome de ação então agir
sem pensar é péssimo pensassem age
identicamente péssimo
a gente sai de imediato ganha
perspectiva ganha inteligência e volta à
vida
quando a gente então volta para a vida a
gente volta pra vida refletidamente de
volta na consciência de si sabendo que a
gente é pequeno sabendo que a gente é
finito
sabendo que a gente é alto insuficiente
a reflexão de novo as quando reflito me
parece que minha dor de dente é a coisa
mais importante do mundo que aquela
minha tia no grupo d o sap na família
matá lá é minha prioridade absoluta no
mínimo sair do grupo
aqui o trabalho que eu tenho que
entregar hoje é a minha vida e eu vou
morrer sem a gente é absorvido por esse
imediato a gente precisa então na
reflexão na volta lucro se com essa
dimensão dimensão e escala o que é isso
na escala da minha vida o que é minha
vida na escala de outras vidas
alguns maravilhosos que eu adoro falam
sobre isso nem se fala sobre isso já foi
citado aqui hoje muito bem a fred fala
não tem nem que eu adoro fala eu peguei
um pedacinho de uma pessoa também já
citado aqui hoje né aqui é um pedaço foi
uma belíssima chamado tabacaria né
álvaro de campos o narrador em grande
mergulho melancólico natal faz uma
enorme viagem melancólica elipê do outro
lado da rua o esteves sem metafísica
o dono da loja da frente é que a cena
pra ele e devolve para a vida
mas essa formulação que o fernando
pessoa faz aqui vi álvaro de campos
ela é clássica de perspectivismo ela não
é pessimista como eventualmente pode
soar eu ligo para vocês
ele esteve sem metafísica ele morrerá eu
morrerei ele deixará a tabuleta eu
deixar diversos
a certa altura morrer a tabuleta também
e os versos também depois de certa
altura morrer a rua em que estava
tabuleta e além de quem for escrito os
versos morrer então planeta gigante em
que tudo isso se deu
isso é para ser pessimista e não vale a
pena é rigorosamente o contrário essa é
a escala do nosso tamanho e escala do
valor da vida
vocês todos já ouviram falar tenho
certeza do que acontece quando uma
pessoa tem uma doença muito grave e
corre o risco de morrer em um acidente e
ela volta infelizmente podendo voltar
ela volta poder saborear a vida muito
melhor
ela entendeu o que é mesmo importante
não é aquela dor de dente não é tia do
lasape coloca em perspectiva coloca-se
em a dimensão não é o próprio a própria
condição de desfrute da vida então de
novo refletir é uma condição de colocar
em esquadro a vida e realmente poder
desfrutá la para falar desse desfrute da
vida também fosse tac não porque eu
também achei uma boa eu adoro o autor
alguém que fala exatamente disso vida
desfrute comprometimento com o fluxo
dela refletido o autor do século 16 que
eu gosto muito chamado michel de
montaigne e ele falou o seguinte em
épocas que pessoas querem ver 150 anos
não sei bem pra quê
a terminar sua vida quando terminar ela
está inteira
a utilidade do river não está na
extensão de tempo mas no uso uma pessoa
viveu um longo tempo no entanto pouco
viveu atentem para isso enquanto estão
aqui têm vivido bastante depende de sua
vontade não do número de anos e se a
companhia pode consolar não vai o mundo
no mesmo passo que o seu é perspectiva
então a pra começar a encaminhar para
minha saída na a ideia é a perspectiva
me dá noção da minha filha estude me dá
a noção da minha auto suficiência da
noção da minha dependência da minha
relação com o outro
o outro que é o outro do amor o outro é
o outro do trabalho o outro é o outro
com quem eu vou conviver depois das
eleições
presumindo que a aniquilação de uma
parte pela outra não
aconteceu assim nós iremos conviver
todos com todos daqui dois meses daqui
quatro meses daqui dez anos
isso também vai passar né essa
perspectiva então eu entendo que só
porque eu duvido se falava de kart eu
sou perfeito
isso já me joga em relação com o outro
de novo o outro do trabalho o outro do
amor o outro amizade um outro social
o outro porque eu tenho empatia porque
se eu sofro ele a sofrer também então
pra como caminho disse que a proposta
pra vocês por trás da idéia de que a
reflexão é um refluxo necessário do
dia-a-dia do mergulho traumático do dia
a dia uma condição de perspectiva que
precisa no entanto devolver a gente pra
vida uma condição de bem viver e
desfrutar plenamente a vida com os
outros não vai haver vida sem outro
ponto que me parece um inimigo ele ainda
é outro mano me parece que ele não faça
como eu ele não pensa se ele pensasse
ele faria como eu
acorda né você tem sua razão os outros
têm suas razões
é preciso ter essa humildade básica de
saber que cada um tem sua razão ea gente
precisa dos outros então eu concluo aqui
uma falha na frase é muito simples linha
mas entendendo a complexidade do mundo
entendendo a complexidade da vida
entendendo que a gente vai viver junto a
uma frase do baú monta terminar que é a
contingência requer a amizade como saída
para o asilo de loucos obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]